you and uh yoshi bach
nudge each other on twitter quite a bit
in the
wonderful intellectual debates
and of course for people who don't know
joshua bach is this brilliant guy he's
been on the podcast a couple times
you tweeted
or he to he tweeted joshua bach everyone
should follow him as well should
definitely follow mr lee cronin and dr
lee cronin
he tweeted dinner with lee cronin we
discussed that while we can translate
every working model of existence into a
turing machine
the structure of the universe might be
given by weeks of non-existence in a
pattern generated by all possible
automata which exists by default
and then he followed on saying face to
face is the best
so the the dinner was face to face what
is joshua talking about
in wakes
quote wakes of non-existence in a
pattern generated by all possible
automata
which exists by default
so
automata exists by default apparently
and then there's wakes of non-existence
what the hell's
non-existence in the universe that's the
top that's
um and also in another conversation
um you tweeted it's state machines all
the way down which presumably is the
origin story of this discussion yeah and
then joshua said
again nudging nudging
nudging slash trolling
joshua said you've seen the light
welcome friend
many foundational physicists effectively
believe in some form of hyper
computation
lee is coming around to this idea and
then you said
i think there are notable differences
first i think the universe does not have
to be a computer second i want to
understand how the universe emerges
constructors that build computers and
third is that there is
uh something below church touring
okay
what the heck is this dinner
conversation about
uh maybe and put another way
maybe zooming out a little bit are there
interesting agreements or disagreements
between you and and joshua bach that uh
that can elucidate some of the other
topics we've been talking about
yeah so yash has an incredible mind and
he has he's so well read
um and
uses language really elegantly it
bamboozles me at times so i'm
uh so often i'm using i'm describing
concepts in a way that
i built from the ground up and so we
misunderstand each other a lot and he's
floating in in the clouds
something like not quite but i think so
there's concept of a turing machine so a
turing machine turing machines
i would argue
um and i think um this is not
the turing machine the universe is not a
turing machine
biology is not even a turing machine
right and because turing machines don't
evolve right there's a there is this
problem that people see chewing machines
everywhere but isn't it interesting the
universe gave rise to biology that gave
rise to intelligence that gave rise to
valenturing who invented the abstraction
of the turing machine
and allowed us to digitize
and
and so
i've been looking for the mystery at the
origin of life the origin of
intelligence and the origin of this and
i when i discussed with yasha i think
yoshi he was saying well the universe of
course the universe is a turing machine
of course there's a there's a hyper
computer there and i've and i think we
got kind of trapped in our words and
terms
because of course it's possible for a
turing machine or computers to exist in
the universe we have them
but what i'm trying to understand is
where did the transition continuous to
discrete occur
and i've been this is because of my
my general foolishness of understanding
the continuous
but
i guess what i'm trying to say is
there were constructors before they were
abstractors
because
how did the universe abstract itself
into existence
and he goes back to earlier saying could
the universe intelligence have come
first what's a constructor what's an
obstructor so the abstractor is the
ability of say
of alan turing and goodell and very and
and church
to in to think about the mathematical
universe
and to label things
and then from those labels to come up
with a set of axioms
with those labels
and to basically understand the universe
mathematically and say okay i can label
things
where did the labeler come from
where is the prime labeler even if the
universe
is not
a touring computer
does that negate the possibility that a
touring computer can stimulate the
universe like just because the
abstraction was formed at a later time
does that mean that abstraction this is
to our cellular automata conversation
yeah we're taking away some of the magic
from the cellular automata because very
intelligent biological systems came up
with that cellular automata well this is
where the existence is the default right
is it does the fact that we exist and we
can come up with a turing machine does
that mean the universe
has to be a turing machine as well
but can it be a touring machine though
that's a
there has to be in the canopy can it be
sure
um
i don't know i don't understand if it
has to be or not can it be
but can the universe have
turing machines in it sure they do exist
now
i'm wondering though
maybe and this is this is really if
things get really hairy
is i think the universe maybe in the
past did not have the computational
power that it has now
this is almost like a
law of physics kind of
so the computational power is not
you can get some free lunch yeah i mean
with the fact that we now we sit here in
this period in time and we can imagine
all these robots and all these machines
and we built them
and so we can easily imagine going back
in time that the universe was capable of
having them but i don't think it can
so the universe may have been a lot
dumber computationally and i think
that's why i don't want to go back to
the time discussion but i think it has
some relationship with it the universe
is basically smarter now than it used to
be and it's going to continue getting
smart smarter over time because of
novelty generation and the ability to
create objects within objects within
objects you know there's a
perhaps there's ground in physics
there's this intuition of conservation
yeah that stuff is concerned like like
you're not you've always had all
everything
you're just rearranging books on the
bookshelf
through time
so you're saying like new books are
being written which laws you want to
break the origin of the origin of the
big bang
you had to break the second law because
we got order for free yeah
well what i'm telling now is that the
energy isn't conserved in the universe
oh it's the second law okay i got you so
because but not in a mad way
okay so
computation
potentially is not conserved which is a
fascinating idea uh intelligence
is not conserved
uh complexity is not conserved
i suppose that's deeply connected to uh
time being fundamental
the natural consequence of that
is if time is fundamental
and the universe is inflating in time
if you like
then there are one or two conservation
laws we need to have a look at
and i wonder if that means the total
energy of the universe is actually
increasing over time
and i might this may be completely
ludicrous but
um we do have all this dark energy
that's
we we have some anomalies let's say
dark matter and dark energy if we don't
add them in
galaxies so dark matter i think doesn't
doesn't hold
you know you need to hold the galaxies
together and there's some other
observational issues could dark energy
just be time
so figuring out what dark energy is
might give us some
uh deep clues about this
not just time but the consequences of
time so it could be that i mean i'm not
saying there's perpetual motions allowed
in this free lunch but i'm saying
if the universe is intrinsically
asymmetric
and it appears to be
um
and it's generating novelty and it
appears to
um couldn't that just be a
mechanistically how reality works
and therefore
um i don't
really like this idea that the and so i
want to live in a deterministic universe
that is undetermined
yeah right the only way i can do that is
that time is fundamental
because otherwise it's all the rest of
us just it's just slight of hand because
the physicist will say yes everything is
deterministic
lieutenant is
newtonian mechanics it's deterministic
quantum mechanics is deterministic let's
take the everedian view
and then basically we can just draw out
this massive universe branching but it
closes again and get it all back and
don't worry your feeling of free will is
effective
but what the physicists are actually
saying is the entire future is mapped
out and that is clearly
problematical
and clearly
um
that's not so clear yeah it's just it's
just problematic
well yeah yeah so it's it's because that
maybe it's just the way it is it's
problematic to you well creature along
this timeline i want to reduce the
number of beliefs i need to understand
the universe
so if time is fundamental i don't need
to have magic order at the beginning and
i don't need a second law but you do
need the magical belief that time is
fundamental well i need the i need the
observation that i'm seeing to be just
like how it is all the way down but the
earth also looks flat
if you cut if you agree
with your observation
so we can't necessarily trust our
observation i know the earth isn't flat
because i can send the satellite into
space like flies you know you're using
the tools of science and the technology
but i'm using what i'm saying i'm going
to do experiments that start to show
i mean i i think that it's worth so
if you can't so if i cannot do an
experiment or a thought experiment that
will test this assumption then the
assumption is without merit really in
the end
you know that's it's fine yeah so that's
a beautiful idea you hold yourself to
that's that's uh that's
given that you think deeply in a
philosophical way you think about some
of these really important
issues and you have theoretical
frameworks like
uh assembly theory
it's really nice that you're always
grounded
with experiment that's what i have
that's so refreshing that's so
beautifully refreshing
you